fait
le ciel de paris n'est ni un lieu
d'exercice il ya lieu de promenade le
ministre de l'intérieur coordonne
l'action pour piéger les avions fantôme
de l'été les rues de rangoon évacués par
l'armée en attendant la succession du
dictateur les étudiants de
l'insurrection aligne les revendications
une deuxième vie commence pour armelle
voiçi après près de trois ans de lutte
elle retrouve ses cinq enfants qui
habitaient avec leur père en algérie
madame monsieur bonsoir difficile
d'affirmer que le ciel d'une
agglomération comme paris souhaite à la
merci d'avion fantômes non identifiés
depuis la fin juillet
l'espace aérien de la capitale a été
violé plusieurs fois en parfaite
illégalité
un arrêté de 1948 interdite en effet le
survol de la capitale ce matin le
ministre de l'intérieur a mis le ciel de
paris sous haute surveillance
il faut bien dire que jusque là les
difficultés de repérage et un manque de
coordination entre les administrations
concernées ont laissé le champ libre à
ses pilotes qualifiés par pierre joxe
d'irresponsables patrice volet des arts
et des aéronefs anonyme dans le ciel de
paris
plusieurs fois depuis 15 jours ulm ou
avion difficile à dire de préférence à
la tombée de la nuit
un jeu dangereux est totalement
interdite par la loi depuis 1948
pas de survol de la capitale à moins de
2000 mètres sauf dérogation pour tout
contrevenant amende ou prison ce matin
pierre joxe a annoncé un renforcement
des groupes prononçons préventive elles
se sont révélées de plus en plus
efficaces on va voir on les adaptera en
cas de besoin on peut accroître le
dispositif par exemple la surveillance
des aérodromes autour de paris on a
commencé avec un rayon de 50 km et on
est passé à 100 km autour de paris
quels moyens vous mettez en place
précisément plusieurs dizaines de
fonctionnaires déjà pour le guet
au total il faut estimer que cette
opération coûte 250 fonctionnaires à peu
près avec la surveillance et puis le
nombre approprié de moyens fournis par
l'armée que je n'ai pas à décrire parce
que il est susceptible de varier d'un
jour à l'autre objectif l'identification
des provocateurs depuis plusieurs jours
ils passent au travers des radars civils
d'orly roissy et athis mons des radars
aveugle à moins de 300 mètres sol seuls
les militaires ont repéré ces avions
fantôme
mais la loi du ciel à paris ne dépend
pas d'eux c'est la sphère de la
préfecture déjà en août 86 albert
maltret avait posé son avion sur les
champs-elysées pour ce pilote
instructeur les contrôles n'amélioreront
en rien la défense aérienne de paris
seul danger qu'il ya certains obstacles
dont il faut voler quand même à 150 200
mètres d'altitude
les guetteurs mis en place ne sont
inefficaces parce que si le pilote a
bien pris le temps de masquer les
manipulations de son avion bon ben on ne
pourra pas l'identifier et ensuite
un hélicoptère contre un avion de
tourisme rapide
cela vient de tourisme qui gagnera
l'hélicoptère ne pourra pas
l'intercepter la guerre du ciel aura
bien lieu à paris avec comme enjeu la
sécurité des parisiens pour le plaisir
de quelques fou d'aviation la politique
mercredi à paris le rpcr et le fln
caisse devrait continuer le dialogue et
discuter de l'avant projet de loi
référendaire sur la nouvelle calédonie
avec le ministre des dom-tom monsieur
louis le pensec deux délégations sont
attendues à paris même si la venue des
représentants du mouvement
indépendantiste kanak reste soumis à
l'aval définitif de son bureau politique
qui se réunit lundi à l'étranger en
birmanie la troupe a commencé d'évacuer
les rues de rangoon et des principales
villes de province
quelques magasins ouverts redonne à la
capitale un semblant de calme après huit
jours d'émeutes qui aurait fait près de
2000 morts
le pays vit dans un état d'apesanteur
politique ce n'est en effet qu'à la fin
de la semaine prochaine que le parlement
birman désignera un successeur au
dictateur déchu sin win
en attendant les étudiants leader de
l'insurrection essaye de se structurer
leurs revendications gilles rabin bruno
carette aujourd'hui
on a même vu des étudiants se balader
dans toute la ville de rangoun
avec une tête planté sur un flic c'est
qui est important je crois que le
mouvement est des étudiantes à conserver
tout à fait le contrôle des événements
ce collectif des étudiants ces
clandestins a fait connaître aux agences
de presse internationales
les six de leurs revendications
c'est à dire la suppression du parti
socialiste la mule le multipartisme et
surtout la création d'un syndicat
étudiant le deuxième point qui me paraît
aussi très important est que cette
victoire des étudiant es tu en grande
partie au soutien que leur ont apporté
les bonzes enfance le fait que les
étudiants aient choisi comme lieu de
refuge ou plus exactement de départ de
leur manifestation
la grande pagode l'achever d'un coup a
été un choix tout à fait judicieux et
qui a frappé la population et ce n'est
pas impossible qu'il décide de pousser
un peu plus loin le mouvement pour se
débarrasser une bonne fois pour toute du
gouvernement une anecdote en tout cas
qu'ils montrent qu'ils lutteraient me
semble-t-il bien l'état d'esprit des
étudiants aujourd'hui ils ont pris le
contrôle d'un commissariat de police
était tenu par une bande de loubards et
bien des étudiants ont mis quasiment aux
arrêts les loubards et ont attiré les
plus
mauvais royaux voilà ces dernières
informations nous était donnée par notre
confrère de radio asie qui est en poste
dans la région
nelson mendela est malade le dirigeant
du congrès national africain incarnation
de la lutte anti-apartheid souffre d'une
infection pulmonaire
un épanchement de la plèvre il a été
hospitalisé mais son état est jugé
satisfaisant le chef de l' insee
condamné à perpétuité en 1964 a fêté
seul dans sa prison son 70e anniversaire
le mois dernier ici on voit madame
mendela dans les rues de johannesburg
la honte dans un paysage de glace note
ces deux pérestroïka ni la transparence
ni la restructuration de mikhaïl
gorbatchev n'ont pour l'instant entamé
la solidité du mur de berlin construit à
l'aube d'un xiii où il y a juste 27 ans
la presse est allemande du jour
justifient encore la nécessité de se
défendre des agressions de l'occident
ronald reagan parle lui du mur comme de
la preuve du rêve manqué du communisme
thierry calmette
faites l'amour pas des murs proclame la
banderole les effigies de michail
gorbatchev souris c'est le 27ème
anniversaire du mur de berlin
côté ouest fanfare zerbe le mur de la
honte est aussi un monument aux morts
13 août 1961 dès le petit matin les
maçons commencent leur besogne sous la
protection de l'armée est allemande
nikita khrouchtchev le numéro un
soviétique réclamer le départ de toutes
les forces d'occupation des familles
sont coupés en deux les allemands de
l'est ne peuvent plus se réfugier à
l'ouest tous les moyens sont bons pour
s'enfuir du tunnel à la montgolfière
depuis 27 ans 77 personnes y ont perdu
la vie en 1963 devant une foule
enthousiaste
le président kennedy lance sa phrase
célèbre je suis un berlinois aujourd'hui
version ouest le mur devient un exutoire
coloré côté est les 55 km qui coupent
berlin en 2 ont été modernisées quatre
fois la surveillance électronique
remplace les champs de mines et les
engins à tir automatique 110 kilomètres
de murs bordeaux si la route qui relie
berlin-ouest à l'allemagne fédérale 27
ans après des points de passage ont été
aménagés entre l'est et l'ouest
les relations commerciales entre les
deux pays s'améliorent quelque porte
donc existe mais comme l'expriment les
graffitis du mur le plus dur est d'en
trouver la clé
exode de plus de 16000 vietnamiens ont
fui clandestinement leur pays et ses
difficultés économiques en mai et juin
de cette année la moitié de ces boat
people ont touché terre à hong kong
mais les autorités de la colonie
britannique leur dénie le statut de
réfugié les négociations sont donc en
cours avec hanoï pour renvoyer ces boat
people chez eux
un palestinien a été tué ce matin par
des soldats israéliens en cours d'une
manifestation dans la bande de gaza
trois autres ont été blessées près de
250 palestiniens ont été tués depuis le
début le 8 décembre de l'intifada le
soulèvement dans les territoires
l'occupation par israël de la
cisjordanie et de gaza n'en finit plus
de diviser les israéliens au sein même
des familles antenne de jérusalem
charles enderlin militants de gauche a
dit au pire à 36 ans il enseigne la
philosophie à l'université hébraïque de
jérusalem pour avoir refusé d'effectuer
une période de réserve en cisjordanie il
vient de purger 21 jours de prison son
père le choix aux pires est écrivain en
1948 il a combattu dans les rangs de
l'irgoun l'organisation clandestine de
menahem begin
il est en désaccord total avec son fils
si les arabes veulent réaliser leur
objectif par la violence il faut leur
barrer la voie par tous les moyens par
la force
il est inutile que jamais de mon père
dans les territoires pour il constate la
souffrance des palestiniens
rien ne le persuadera que la seule voie
c'est le dialogue pas la matraque
quand je suis allé à la manifestation
devant la prison
j'ai dit aux hamid a dit je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous je suis seulement
venu pour mon fils j'ai eu des jours
très dur car je connais mon garçon je
sais ce qu'il a subis en prison
je ne croyais pas qu'on perd irait aussi
loin
je savais qu'il était capable de faire
la différence entre la politique et la
vie privée qui me soutiendrait en tant
que père mais qu'ils aillent manifester
devant la prison où il était détenu
ça ça m'a surpris ça m'a fait du bien
tôt je suis inquiet parce que le feu du
sionisme
la vision sioniste sont aujourd'hui en
perte de vitesse refus de servir dans
les territoires c'est comme planter des
piquets au bord de l'abyme ou risquent
de tomber la démocratie israélienne
s'est tracé une ligne blanche
je regrette qu'ils se trompent
mais c'est mon fils je pense que mon
père représente la peur juive une peur
que l'on peut comprendre mais avec
laquelle toute politique est impossible
nous devons libérer la politique
israélienne de cette peur là et dans
quelques mois lors ce qu'a dit
retournera en prison après avoir refusé
un nouvel ordre de marche et au choix
ira manifester avec les pacifistes
contre ces idées mais pour son fils
série d'attentats tôt ce matin contre
des concessionnaires automobiles
français dans le nord de l'espagne sept
au total des dégâts mais pas de victime
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
revendication remarquera simplement que
le thé à est coutumière de ce type
d'action à dublin l'armée républicaine
irlandaise l'ira à revendiquer tout à
l'heure l'assassinât d'un
ni terres britanniques qui appartenant à
l'armée du rhin c'est alors qu'il
rentrait chez lui hier soir via le port
belge d'ostende que richard et qui n'a
été tué au volant de sa voiture il
s'apprêtait à prendre le ferry pour
douvres et pour des vacances en famille
le dossier des couples mixtes franco
algérien elle retrouve enfin ses cinq
enfants elle s'est armée le bois qu elle
s'est battue pendant près de trois ans
pour revoir ses cinq enfants restés en
algérie avec leur père après le divorce
et puis pères et mères se sont écrits et
retrouver il y a eu arrangement à
l'amiable dans un contexte favorable
paris et alger se sont en effet accordés
sur ce dossier pascal deschamps patrick
gab et comment vous dire tant qu'ils ont
eu pendant mes bras mais je suis très
très heureuse a fait au moins cinq
niches et pendant quelques instants plus
tard l'avions supposé et armelle voix
suave oublier toutes ces craintes
enfin presque les deux plus jeunes ne
l'ont pas encore reconnu katie t'a
reconnu manquer petit fils il est fait
appel mais ma mort oui non
pendant trois ans armelle voit le sua
tout essayé pour faire rentrer sa
famille en décembre dernier les deux
aînés sont bienvenues à rennes mais
seulement pour les vacances de noël
comme une trentaine d'autres enfants
dans leur cas ils ont repris le chemin
de l'algérie enfin il ya quelques mois
son mari accepte de revenir
définitivement armes elle lui a même
trouvé du travail
aujourd'hui dans son petit appartement
de rennes les enfants retrouvent
sinon leurs habitudes du moins quelques
joueuses oublié quant à armel elle ne
pense déjà plus à ses trois années de
solitude apprendre à faire la cuisine en
plus ça avance très vite fait ménard
était petit c'est également là surtout
qu'il adore les merguez a longtemps que
kim réclament et des merguez mois de
décembre dans mon manger parce qu'elle
est tout heureux de vous revoir tendent
à cette fin
certes tous les problèmes ne sont pas
encore résolus
il va falloir veiller à l'adaptation
scolaire des enfants et reprendre une
vie de couple comme si rien ne s'était
passé
mais lequel cette famille est
exceptionnelle car pour un père qui
accepte que les enfants rentrent en
france
il en reste encore beaucoup qui ne
veulent rien entendre
mais pour nous le problème central c'est
tout même le cas des pères irréductibles
je dirais et là la convention implique
nécessite la mise en place de cette
fameuse commission mixte franco
algérienne qui examinera les dossiers
or notre grande déception c'est que
depuis deux mois elle n'est pas encore
en place
la commission mixte franco algérienne
vient enfin d'être constituée elle
devrait se réunir le 23 août prochain à
alger sur la table de négociations des
dizaines de cas de mer qui comme armel
voix chu attendent depuis parfois de
nombreuses années le retour de leurs
enfants le mari dormait gouache veut
retrouver du travail en france
difficultés classiques sur la route des
vacances aujourd'hui les bouchons en
région lyonnaise et sur la route de
l'espagne et des accidents qui ont fait
sept morts et plusieurs blessés dans le
cher c'est une conductrice qui s'est
endormi au volant dans les yvelines
c'est un dépassement dangereux même
imprudence dans le loir et cher pour un
conducteur de 21 ans
tué sur le coup un ministre disait hier
que c'était un devoir civique pour les
médias de répéter prudence c'est fait
notez qu'en seine-saint-denis huit
automobilistes ont fait l'objet d'une
suspension immédiate du permis de
conduire ce matin pour excès de vitesse
il y a donc la prudence mais aussi
l'idée qu'il faut profiter sur la route
de toutes les occasions de se détendre
jean-claude brami vincent maillard
week-end du 15 août grand départ et
grand retour se croisent énervement
chaleur et parfois accidents sont
malheureusement au rendez vous depuis le
début des vacances de bilan est lourd
alors ne roulait pas idiot arrêtez-vous
souvent d'autant que vous n'avez plus
d'excusés même pour déjeuner tout est
prévu
en effet jusqu'au 15 septembre les
boutiques d'autoroute affichant la
vignette prix/produit pique nique vous
offrent de quoi manger à des prix
raisonnables
je vous l'accordé volontiers
il ne s'agit pas d'un repas princier
mais après tout en voiture manger léger
plutôt conseillé non
calis nathalie mode et alexandra ont
depuis longtemps adopté cette formule
elles arriveront à noirmoutier lieu de
leurs vacances un peu plus tard mais
sûrement beaucoup plus décontracté il en
est d'autres qui tiennent à leur petit
confort
qu'à cela ne tienne il existe pour eux
de véritables aire de repos sur toutes
les autoroutes le déjeuner terminé il
est temps de reprendre la route
quant à vous madame bon appétit on peut
en rire on peut en sourire mais quand ça
dure le bruit lancinant atteint le
système nerveux fatigue les neurones et
inciterait parfois le temps d'un flash
au meurtre que tout être civilisé
entendant son voisin ronfler se refusera
pourtant à commettre nous allons parler
des ronfleurs toléré par une personne
seule est encore dans l'intimité d'une
chambre à coucher
le phénomène dû à une déficience de
cloison nasale devient littéralement
catastrophe quand il s'exprime en plein
air dans les terrains de camping et manu
et le vannier luc bachofen 35 degrés à
l'ombre
la sieste ici tout semble calme luxe et
volupté
mais ça n'est qu'une apparence car la
réalité sonore ressemble plus souvent à
ceux ci
ma mère rentre mon père en route
je suis passé sérénité un conflit les
chevaux le ronfleur la terreur des
campings l'indoor les autres essayent au
delà du comique de la situation le
ronflement est aujourd'hui considéré
comme le symptôme d'une véritable
affection respiratoire du un
développement trop important du voile du
palais et de la luette qui vibre
bruyamment respirer en ronflant demande
beaucoup d'efforts un ronfleur disent
les médecins c'est souvent un asphyxié
qui s'ignore nous sommes en présence de
patients qui ont des difficultés
d'oxygénation de leur sang pendant la
nuit et peuvent développer à différentes
de différentes façons par exemple une
hypertension artérielle ou une
somnolence diurne c'est à dire des
endormissements excessive et répété
inexpliqué dans la journée voire même
une certaine asthénie c'est-à-dire
fatigue intellectuelle ou psychique
au cours de leur fournit la solution
pour les cas extrêmes la chirurgie on
coupe la luette afin qu'elle ne vibre
plus 40 minutes d'intervention sous
anesthésie générale
une opération parfois douloureuses pour
les patients mais pour les voisins en
camping ou non quel soulagement
la communauté économique européenne
débloque une somme de 300 mille francs
pour aider l'institut national de la
protection de l'environnement des pays
bas à lutter contre l'épidémie qui
décime actuellement les phoques en mer
du nord depuis que nous avons ouvert ce
dossier c'était en début de semaine le
mal à gagner les détroits du danemark
dans la baltique et le golfe de botnie
l'espèce rare du phoque gris est elle
même menacée la suite de l' enquête de
notre envoyé spécial
jacques doué pour la deuxième fois
aujourd'hui ian plonge dans l'eau glacée
de la mer du nord sur un banc de sable
nos dizaines de phoques agonise il faut
agir très vite
victime d'un mystérieux virus ce fois
que ne peut plus respirer ses plumes en
sont pleins de sang
yann n'est pas vétérinaire mais
instituteur lui et son équipe de
bénévoles ont appris les gestes qui
sauvent est aujourd'hui
on signale des phoques malades partout
le long des côtes
le centre de sauvetage de tin est
débordé les îles voisines envoi par
avion les animaux trouvés sur les plages
premiers soins un pub pour dégager les
voies respiratoires et un puissant
antibiotique
au centre on essaie de sauver les moins
atteints le plus urgent enrayé
l'infection et éviter les contagions la
température doit descendre
impérativement à 35 degrés
certains animaux présente tous les
symptômes d'une infection généralisée
malheureusement c'est trop tard pour eux
pour les plus faibles une chance l'avion
spécial du centre hôpital de
peterborough en hollande
spécialisé dans l'accueil des phoques
c'est le seul établissement en europe
depuis quatre mois
6000 phoques sont morts atteint d'une
maladie inconnue dû à ce virus
un tiers des animaux vivants entre la
mer du nord et la baltique l'hôpital
depuis tervuren est aussi débordés on y
soigne 90 phoques dont 50 sont touchés
par le virus mortel la capacité de ce
centre d'accueil ne dépasse pas la
quarantaine
les installations permettent cependant
d'isoler les cas les plus graves et
d'étudier le comportement des animaux
certains très affaibli ne se nourrissent
plus eux mêmes
alors on les aide
mais c'est surtout la recherche d'un
remède effet place qui préoccupent les
chercheurs du centre lice védère la
vétérinaire de l'hôpital teste
actuellement un vaccin qu'elle a mis au
point pour faire face à la maladie virus
est inconnu quand c'est la première fois
que nous le trouvons chez ces animaux
ils leur donnent tous les symptômes
d'une pneumonie et malheureusement il
meurt en quelques heures sur son banc de
sable celui ci a eu l'oeil crevé par les
oiseaux
mais il est sauvé tout le monde attend
ici les résultats des tests
il faut quinze jours pour en connaître
l'efficacité quinze jours de soins
intensifs
les équipes sur les nuitées jours au
chevet des animaux malades dont le
regard nous interpelle nous n'avons pas
de solution pour le moment pas de remède
notre travail consiste à chercher quel
est ce nouveau virus et pourquoi
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas de
réponse pour le combattre nous essayons
un vaccin en espérant que les fabriquent
eux mêmes un anticorps contre le virus
nous avons déjà vaccinés et mis en
observation une cinquantaine d'animaux
certains trouvent cette lutte inutile
accusant la pollution de la mer du nord
c'est vrai la mer du nord est une
poubelle
mais at elle donné naissance au virus
mortel d'autres disent laissez les
phoques en paix les plus forts
survivront de même disparition de
pauline lafont dans les cévennes
l'actrice a quitté jeudi matin la
résidence de la famille pour une
promenade les recherches se sont
poursuivies tout cet après midi entre
saint-andré-de-valborgne esman c'est
dans les départements du gard une région
très escarpée et sauvage se sont toutes
les informations dont on dispose est
tout à l'heure mais une dernière dépêche
nous apprend que les enquêteurs
ils sont une cinquantaine qui
recherchent donc pauline lafont sur le
terrain ont abandonné leurs recherches
ce soir qu'il privilégie pour l'instant
l'hypothèse d'un enlèvement ou d'une
fugue
alors que
frère de la comédienne préfère lui
penser qu'elle a pu disparaître dans une
région qui est très accidentée qu'elle
est plus être qu'elle a pu être
grièvement blessé lors d'une promenade
en montagne pauline lafont
en sport la dernière chance pour les
athlètes français de se qualifier pour
séoul à l'occasion des championnats de
france d'athlétisme qui se déroule
jusqu'à demain à tours parmi les
qualifiés de la journée laurence bily du
racing club de france sur 100 m philippe
tourre et de créteil devrait s'assurer
le 110 m haies
la grosse satisfaction pour stéphane
caristan sortant de blessure et mon camp
d'entraînement
il a assuré sa qualification sur cette
même distance
une consolation alors qu'il perdait
jeudi son titre de champion d'europe
anne mourgues la course de la dernière
chance pour stéphane caristan la
dernière chance balle à séoul minima
imposés par la fédération 13 secondes 60
centièmes meilleur temps de caristan 40
centièmes de moins une qualification à
la portée du créteil où il a décidé de
tout miser sur les séries s'il est
qualifié il ne dispute pas la finale
caristan prend la tête dès le départ et
contrôler la course de bout en bout
seule difficulté les trois dernières eux
et qu'il a du mal à négocier
treize secondes 47 100e entend corriger
billets pour séoul en poche pari réussi
un super temps pour caristan ne s'est
plus entraîné sur 110 m haies depuis six
mois il a perdu son record d'europe
jeudi un cariste ans motivé comme jamais
pendant treize secondes 47 centièmes il
oublie tout laon plâtre qu'il porte à la
cuisse droite les blessures à répétition
depuis plusieurs saisons objectif séoul
quelle que soit la manière
c'est des fois je savais que je serai
difficile en fin de course mais le
montage chez moi et au point et
j'éprouve aujourd'hui que je peux entrer
n'importe comment saison avec un bon
temps de référence
caristan ne devrait pas partir salle aux
jeux olympiques
philippe tourre et son camarade
d'entraînement a remporté le titre 110 m
haies en 13 secondes 62 centièmes 200e
au dessus des minima mais les
sélectionneurs devrait le laisser partir
caristan tour est le ticket gagnant
coc dans cinq semaines le tiercé
d'enghien de cet après-midi la
combinaison gagnante 19-12 elle rapporte
pour 5 francs dans l'ordre 267 francs 50
et dans un ordre différent 53 francs 50
le quarté + 10 9 12 et droit dans
l'ordre pour seafrance 744 francs dans
un ordre différent en 93 francs il y à
un tiercé demain de ville voici les
pronostics de pierrette brès pour ce
tiercé dominicale le 5 et le 9 le 16 le
4 le 1 le 14 le 6 et le 12
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant vous avez rendez vous avec
laurent cabrol pour une météo qui
s'annonce bonne pour demain le prochain
journal par bernard pradines hausse et à
00h30
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur antenne 2 et je vous retrouve demain
à